mais d'abord on revient sur cette
initiative atypique des centaines de
sous vêtements seraient en passe
d'arriver sur le bureau de jean castex
une démarche
culotté initiée par les propriétaires de
boutiques de lingerie pour protester
contre la fermeture de leur commerce dit
non essentiels florent cave elle est
allée à la rencontre des manuels une
vendômoise qui a décidé elle aussi de ne
pas faire dans la dentelle
alors voici la culotte que j'ai envoyée
à jean castex 1 dans le cadre de notre
action à culotté une culotte s'en fout
front pour le premier ministre pour un
message sobre mais efficace
emmanuel limoges tient un commerce de
lingerie commerce jugés non essentiels
fermé depuis trois semaines il ne
rouvrira pas avant la mi mai une
restriction qui indignent la vendômoise
aujourd'hui honnêtement c'était une
cliente sur dix qui rentre pour un
acheté séduction les neuf autres c'est
un besoin un besoin parce
qu'effectivement elle ne supporte plus
les armatures parce que l on changeait
taille il ya des mamans qui viennent
accoucher qu'on venant de soutiens gorge
d'allaitement et on est là pour les
accompagner comme emmanuel elles sont
plus de 200 avoir envoyé une petite
culotte à jean castex démarré sur les
réseaux sociaux le mouvement ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur
pas question de garder le petit doigt
sur la couture du slip
car en tant que chef d'entreprise
emmanuel n'a pas droit au chômage
partiel et les aides de l'état sont
incertaines on ne sait pas ce qu'on va
toucher pour pour le mois d'avril
puisque le décrit en fait tu vas
parraitre que début ou mi mai est par
contre il faut continuer à payer nos
charges fife les loyers l'électricité
l'ensemble des
il marche on dit ce qu'on a reçu et
aujourd'hui donc c'est sur nos propres
économique on doit effectivement
survivre les rares clients venus
chercher leurs articles en click and
collect sont solidaires de l'initiative
on peut le voir ici schéma il ya quand
même des mesures de distanciation qui
sont importants qui a tendance
il ya un client ou deux clients qui
peuvent rentrer point final non moi je
trouve que c'est pas très normal
jean castex cédera-t-il devant la fronde
des petites culottes
nul doute que le premier ministre saura
répondre en politique comme en lingerie
brodé est un art